they are the ones who are actually
injecting racism they always tell us
we're the racists but they are the ones
injecting racism into any absolutely
everything every institution it's
incredible I saw this tweet by Charlie
Kirk this is this is unbelievable he
says this is the pentagon's diversity
Chief saying she's exhausted by white
folks with an ex we are not a serious
country and it's true this woman Kalisa
Wing is the pentagon's diversity Chief
so that means the Pentagon hired someone
to instill racism within the Pentagon
and here's what she wrote a while back a
while back this is freaking a week ago
I'm so exhausted at these white folks in
these PD sessions this lady actually has
the cow docity Caucasian uh you see what
she's doing there to say that black
people can be racist too I had to stop
the session and give Karen the business
we are not the majority we don't have
power uh and then she put a threat out
first off Kelly's say you're racist you
are racist black people can be racist
Asian people can be racist white people
can be racist Jews can be racist Muslims
can be racist if you judge a person
based on the color of their skin or
their immutable characteristics you
basically are racist okay I know you
guys have created your new definition of
this having something to do with power
but I'm fairly certain when you have the
black supremacist society that you want
ushered in by the Democrats uh and
you're racist against white people
you're not going to call that racism
right it'll somehow be justified in the
name of social justice
[Music]
thank you